i'm in the kitchen with fellow actress
and foodies
so much and
i am going to learn a recipe of hers
you're in the driver's seat i'm in your
car baby take it away are we what are we
making we are making it's very english
it's a roast beef so you get this is the
beef and then you stuff little bits of
garlic
into these
pre-made holes pre-made holes yes you
can shove it in i see it yes and then
you can rub it with the salt and pepper
and some thyme
and sort of rub that in
mm-hmm it can also be like bread
[Laughter]
all right
you wanna
and then you rub rub and then you can
flip
get in there
oh she likes us all i do too
[Laughter]
[Applause]
okay so then that's that and then we're
gonna put that in the oven perfect okay
can we do that open the oven for you
thank you darling the teamwork makes the
dream work it does indeed you put the
roast oh it's the in the oven piece of
beef there we go and then we've got
we're going to do roast potatoes which
obviously there's not a proper roast if
there aren't roast potatoes so you've
got the oil i do that's vegetable oil
and olive oil you have to add some
butter
of course you do
and then you parboil the potatoes
here's one we made earlier and i yeah
normally i would heat that up first so
that then when you put them in it goes
so remember that oh so this should be
like boiling it can be boiling oh and
then you have little burns all over you
look there are cooking burns oh my god
you do have little and this is slightly
tipsy the other day trying to make a ham
sandwich when i got home oh
we've all been there and then
oh yeah so that was that weird so would
we put this in the oven then as well
we'd put this in the oven and you want
to cover it with all that like yum oh my
god it's basically it's called a roast
potato but i put so much oil and butter
in that it basically fries the potato
it's like ginormous french fries because
i'm looking at the end result and i'm
dying over there a little bit of that
pinch of salt and then when you get it
in the door for me perfect
oh my god i love cooking with you
it's so nice
perfect
the potatoes are in
we've got and then we have a creamy leek
and a gravy the gravy is essential this
is the creamy leek
it's like a bechamel nom noms and then
this gravy it's kind of like a family
recipe this
it's pretty delish i love leeks so much
i love gravy i almost i always want to
just like drink it as a soup that much
of a
oh so good those leeks the creamy leaves
stand it all right
i really do
all of these steps
and tips and the complete navigational
culinary map will be on our website at
the drewberrymore show.com
and
um
yeah potato you want these you've got i
do by the way you know me i was
literally like you can barely
look at them they call me the seagull
i heard that it's true
i heard it and i was sealing for those
potatoes you might have met your match
with a fellow seagull
and then i'm england i mean i love the
gravy i love to like have it swimming i
don't know how much baby gravy is
craving me girl craving me baby i want
you to slap that beef again
i'm gonna wake up laughing it's like by
the way i was just about to say when i'm
like hitting the pillow tonight yeah
you're not giggling
about you and me
such a perfect sound
this is one gorgeous
gorgeous play mode oh sienna miller
everybody go to the drewberrymart
show.com website it's so good
oh my god oh my god i crashed
[Applause]
get your plate of food get your bottle
of wine get whatever it is that's your
accoutrements that you like to settle in
because when you pick up that remote
control and you start watching the show
you're not going to be able to stop it's
so good it's best in class it's anatomy
of a scandal it's available april 15th
on netflix and you're going to really
enjoy the ride it's incredible santa
thank you
[Music]